well here's some video i think it's from
msnbc uh fauci uh discussing vaccinated
people who have the delta variant and
you know what i'm not even going to
color this with anything listen to it
and tell me if something seems weird
related to vaccines and what we've been
sold
now that we have a delta variant that
has changed the entire landscape because
when you look at the level of virus in
the nasopharynx of a vaccinated person
who gets a breakthrough infection with
delta
it is exactly the same as the level of
virus in a unvaccinated person who's
infected
that's the problem so those data were
very compelling
and that triggered the change in the cdc
guideline
so just to be clear what lord fauci just
said is that whether you're vaccinated
or not the virus level that you'll have
because of the delta variant will be
exactly the same okay so i'll just
assume that that's true in this case
right i'm going to take his word for it
he's fouchy he has given us information
we must must believe it now we were told
that the vaccines joe biden's words you
know once you take the vaccine you can
get back out there do your thing then of
course the delta variant comes and you
know
and then the woman at costco and all of
it um but
that sort of sounds like he's an
anti-vaxxer in a way you told us that if
we all got vaccinated we're good to go
everything will open up and actually not
only did he do that you used to say 14
days to or what was it 14 or 15 days to
flatten the curve 14 15 days who's
counting at this point yeah that was
almost two years ago at this point um
that was before a vaccine had even been
thought of right like right at the
beginning of this thing there was no
chance uh and by the way when trump was
you know doing operation warp speed and
they were speeding up the vaccines
everyone on msnbc and cnn was saying who
would take this who trusts cnn the cdc
and who trusts uh trump and all that
stuff now if you say that about the
administration you're you're on one of
aoc's list uh but the point here is and
i'll take his word for it that if you
take the vaccine the vir the level of
the virus his words is just as bad
whether you're vaccinated or not well
that sort of is telling people not to
get vaccinated isn't it isn't it kind of
saying well this stuff that you sold us
this bill of goods that you sold us
isn't what was promised and on top of it
uh just now i think biden's having a
press conference this afternoon but some
of it's leaking they're saying that
every federal employee will have to be
vaccinated without choice and every
contractor that works with the federal
government will have to have all of
their employees vaccinated so it's like
the mandate is here and by the way guys
you may remember on july 30th the last
day that i spent online before
disappearing i was banned from twitter
and why was i banned from twitter
because i said basically that the
vaccines aren't working as promised
which that obviously is true and i'm not
telling you not to get vaccinated you
should get vaccinated if you want to get
vaccinated you absolutely should and you
should wear a mask if you want to wear a
mask and you should live in an
underground bunker if you want to live
in an underground bunker actually i'd
prefer if a lot of these people did just
stay there stay down there we'll send
you stuff care package
um but i was banned because i said
obviously the vaccines aren't working
and obviously federal mandates are
coming that got me banned from twitter
of course then i fought back and
fortunately because of
reubenreport.locals.com i had a way of
getting my message out there instead of
just being completely uh you know being
completely wiped away from the internet
in essence um
well it turns out that the thing that i
got banned for that eventually twitter
did apologize and they said it was an
error well that's pretty much what
they're all saying right now so dave
rubin the crescent of youtube uh by the
way just a couple other quick crazy
covet things here this is from the new
york post a new jersey student has said
he is barred from taking classes at
rutgers university because he has not
been vaccinated even though he's only
studying virtually from home
he was locked out of his rutgers email
and related accounts when he went to pay
his tuition at the end of last month and
was told that he needed to be vaccinated
even though he has no plans to attend in
person
do you think that this thing is
expanding
does any of this feel like it has
anything to do with kovid do i seem like
a complete conspiracy theorist to you
maybe maybe i do
maybe i don't but i dig you and i thank
you for watching